[Music]
the most important part about being real
isn't what you're made of
it's about what's in your heart
faith
[Applause]
she brings to those who love
[Music]
the sweet fulfillment of
the sacred
[Music]
[Music]
steps in and sees you through
[Music]
your dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
i present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only
[Applause]
hello pups
jumping keepers and almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
i will be right here when you get back
pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience
can you imagine the trouble he's gonna
get into wouldn't want that on my
conscience everybody who's anybody wants
to be a somebody but i want to be real
why on earth would you want to be real
when you can be
famous
[Music]
pinocchio should have been home by now
you won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
pinocchio
be brave
[Music]
truthful
not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person pinocks
oh what's happening jiminy looks like
some sort of fairy magic kinda on the
nose if you ask me
[Music]
you